I don't really talk about my business I
talk about the movement and you too are
talking about the movement you know that
it became a movement and you were you
were involved you were one of the
leaders of the movement when I think
about the Legacy and the impact that I
want to have it's how many people did
anything that I put out
how many of them were sent in a
different direction because of something
that I did or said so rather than
thinking about scale so it doesn't
matter if you had a hundred thousand
people or a hundred million people it's
more about
for the short period in which you were
here which might be a year it might be a
lifetime what is the impact that you had
on culture on business on our flash or
whatever it is that sends people in a
different direction